the graph below shows the percentage of
American adults who smoke over time
assuming the trend shown in the data has
been consistent since 1945 used the
graph to estimate the percentage of
American adults who smoked in 1945 so
let's see what's going on here the
horizontal axis here they say years
since 1965 so this point right over here
this is zero years since 1965 so this
really represents 1965 and we see it
looks like around let's see if I were to
eyeball it it looks like it's around 42%
of Americans just looking at this graph
another side of the exact number roughly
41 or 42 percent of Americans smoked in
1965 based on this graph and then five
years later this would be 1970 ten years
later that would be nineteen nineteen
seventy five and they don't they don't
sample the data or we don't have data
from every given year this is just from
some of the years that we happen to have
but what it is clear it looks like we
have a negative linear relationship
right over here that it would not be
difficult to fit a line so let me try to
do that so I'm just going to eyeball it
and try to fit a line to this data so
that our line might look something like
that
so it looks like a pretty strong
negative linear relationship when I say
it's a negative linear relationship we
see that as time increases the
percentage of smokers in the US is
decreasing so that's what makes it a
negative a negative relationship now
what are they asking they want us to
estimate the percentage of American
adults who smoked in 1945 well 1945
would be to the left of zero so we could
even think of it as if 1945 is 20 years
before 1965 so let me see if I can draw
that so 20 years before 1965 let's see
this would be five years before 1965 10
years 15 years 20 years before 1965 so I
could even put that as negative 20 right
over here negative 20 years since 1965
you could view as 20 years before 1965
so that would represent 1945
there and one thing that we could do is
very roughly just try to extend to this
negative or linear relationship
backwards and they allow us to do that
by saying assuming the trend shown and
the data has been consistent so the
trend has been consistent this line
represents the trend so let's just keep
going backwards keep going backwards at
the same rate so something something
like that I want to make sure that it
looks looks at the same looks like it's
the same rate right over here and you
could just try to eyeball it you could
say will exceed 20 years ago 1945 if I
were to extend that line backwards it
looks like it looks like there were
about 52% of the population was smoking
this seems it seems like we're about 52
percent right over here another way to
think about it was B to actually try to
calculate the rate of decline and let's
say we do it over every 20 years because
that'll be useful because we're going 20
years back so if we go 20 years from
this point so this is 1965 you go 20
years in the future so that is that is
10 years and then that is 20 years so my
change in the horizontal is 20 years
what's the change in the vertical well
it looks like it looks like we have a
decrease of a little bit more than 10%
looks like it's 11 or 12% decrease so
I'll just say minus 11 percent right
there let's see if that's consistent if
we were to go another 20 years so if we
go another 20 years it looks like once
again we've gone down by about 10
percent so that looks like roughly 10
percent if we're following the line it
should actually be the same number so so
let me write it this way it's it's
approximately down 10%
so that little squiggly line I'm just
saying approximately negative 10% every
20 years negative 10% every 20 years so
if you go back 20 years so if you go
back 20 years
you should increase you should increase
your percentage by 20 percent so this
should go up by or you should increase
your printer
percent I should say so if we started at
41 or 42 once again this is what we saw
when we just eyeballed it you should get
to 51 or 52 percent so my estimate of
the percentage of American adults who
smoked in 1945 would be 51 or 50 52
percent